Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, die 2. in der Bundesliga. Sie läuft schon seit fünf Spieltagen. Höchste Zeit, mal ein kleines erstes Zwischenfazit zu ziehen. Hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 226. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ja, die Kurzpässe, sie gehen weiter. Noch nicht im wöchentlichen Rhythmus, aber das werdet ihr ja alles herausfinden. Wir wollen heute sprechen über die 2. Männer Bundesliga. Die haben wir bisher streiflich vernachlässigt. Hatte ein bisschen mit der Frauen-EM auch zu tun. 5 Spieltage sind nun gespielt. Jetzt wollen wir mal auf das Tabellenbild gucken und uns ein bisschen mehr Zeit nehmen für zwei Vereine. Ihr dürft jetzt raten, welche Vereine, wenn ich die Gäste vorstelle. Zum einen eine völlig unbekannte Stimme aus dem Rasenfunk. Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Podcast und für tausend anderen Dingen auch. Hallo Eva, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist.
Danke, Max, für die Einladung. Ich finde es sehr schön, dass du deinen Versprechen gehalten hast und mich trotzdem weiterhin einlässt.
Da konnten wir uns doch beide sicher sein. Und ich freue mich total auf den Braunschweig-Schwerpunkt mit dir. Das wird super. Ja, ich bin in erstaunlicher, erschreckender Frühform. Begrüßen wir lieber noch Tobias Kröger hier von transfermarkt.de, der Ed Tobias Kröger auf Twitter. Ihr habt ihn ja hier im Rasenfunk auch schon gehört. Das letzte Mal war es, glaube ich, Tobias, also in der Endphase der Saison. Und als man es auch noch direkt hochgehen hätte können für den HSV. Hallo Tobi.
Moin Max, danke für die Einladung. Freue mich sehr, hier zu sein. Und ja, damals hatte ich noch Hoffnung, dass es in die Bundesliga wieder hochgeht. Oh Gott, ist die Hoffnung jetzt schon wieder weg? Aber wie wir jetzt wissen, es hat nicht geklappt und die Hoffnung ist irgendwo im Hintergrund wieder da. Aber ich versuche sie noch zu ignorieren.
Okay, okay, ich sehe schon, es wird wieder Teile einer Selbsthilfetherapie haben. Aber so ist das eben. Wenn man Fußballfan ist generell, das hat eigentlich nichts mit der Liga zu tun. Diese Geschichten schreibt der Fußball nämlich wirklich. Wir hängen uns an ihn dran. Und er macht uns Freude, enttäuscht uns aber auch. Also dann blicken wir mal auf die Tabelle. Wenn ich da jetzt einfach so drauf gucke, Eva, dann sehe ich auf Platz 1 Paderborn mit 12 Punkten, Darmstadt auf Platz 2 mit 12 Punkten, Heidenheim 10, Kaiserslautern mit 10 auf Rang 4. Sind wir da schon bei der ersten Überraschung angelandet? Was siehst du, wenn du auf die Tabellenspitze guckst? Und wer überrascht dich denn da?
Ja, also ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall Kaiserslautern, also dass sie so weit oben stehen. Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich durchaus erwartet, dass sie so der Verein sein werden, die von allen drei Aufsteigern wahrscheinlich am besten in der Liga ankommen, auch vom Kader her und vielleicht auch einfach von der Euphorie, die man irgendwie mitgezogen hat. Aber ich muss halt auch irgendwie gestehen, dass Paderborn so gut performt, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Also ich fand schon, dass da viel Gutes passiert ist. Ich habe auch eher gesagt, ich siedel sie im oberen Teil der Tabelle an für diese Saison. Aber gut 18 geschossene Tore, alleine sieben davon am Wochenende. Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen schön, weil es so ein bisschen das Paderborn ist, was man eigentlich kennt. Also Paderborn ist für mich wirklich so der Innenbegriff der zweiten Liga. Das meine ich überhaupt nicht respektlos oder so. Aber ich finde irgendwie Paderborn-Spiele, da kann wirklich alles passieren. Das kann durch, also eigentlich geht so ein Spiel meistens nicht 0-0 aus, wenn Paderborn beteiligt ist. Das ist irgendwie als neutraler Zuschauer, Zuschauerin natürlich immer schon mal schön, sich 8-0-0s hintereinander anzugucken. Macht jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Aber es ist natürlich auch defensiv zum Teil manchmal so ein kleines Festival, das war ja unter Baumgart schon so. Ist schön, dass Quassenjohn das irgendwie so ein bisschen übernommen hat. Er hat ja auch vor dem Spiel gegen Kiel gesagt, das wird ein Torfestival. Es hätte glaube ich zwischendurch auch fast 6-6 ausgehen können, so wie auch die Paderbornadefensive zum Ende der ersten Hälfte gespielt hat. Aber ja, also, dass sie so gut drauf sind, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht. Aber ich glaube, die muss man auf jeden Fall auch nennen, weil eben doch vielleicht nicht, ich weiß, so Hamburg, Düsseldorf waren halt so die Namen, die bei vielen auch bei mir irgendwie unter den Top 2 waren und dass sie es halt erstmal nicht sind, sondern eben Paderborn, Darmstadt, die aber ja ehrlich gesagt auch zur Rückrunde hin letzte Saison durchaus gezeigt haben, was sie drauf haben.
Tobias, magst du da was ergänzen, wenn wir auf die Spitze gucken?
Ich kann Eva eigentlich zustimmen. Bei Kaiserslautern auf jeden Fall, ja, mit denen hatte ich gar nicht oben gerechnet. Ich muss auch sagen, bei Kaiserslautern war ich vor der Saison ein bisschen zwiegespalten, weil es halt auch wieder dieser klassische Traditionsverein ist, wo man auch nicht weiß, wie starten die in die Saison rein und dann kann auch mal so ein Stadion dann auch recht schnell, schon schnell wieder zur Last werden, wenn es halt nicht läuft. Aber auch wenn es gut läuft, da wirklich die Euphorie mitnehmen, was sie auch zum Glück geschafft haben. Und ja, bisher überrascht mich auch einfach, wie sie diese Leidenschaft, die sie aus dem Ausstieg auch mitgenommen haben, jetzt auf den Platz bringen können. Also wenn man sich die Spiele von Kaiserslautern anguckt, dann sieht man auch wirklich, da wird ein Gegner niedergekämpft, so ein typischer Dirk-Schuster-Fußball. Aber dann hast du trotzdem noch so Spieler wie Mike Wunderlich, die dann auch nochmal so die spielerische Komponente mit reinbringen. Und bisher ist es wirklich eine gute Mischung. Und ich habe mir auch schon selber gedacht, okay, eigentlich jeder Gegner hofft gerade nicht, auf den Metzenberg zu müssen, gerade am Saisonanfang, weil sie jetzt gerade in dieser Phase sind, wo es wirklich ganz, ganz schwer ist, dort zu bestehen.
Da würde ich ganz gerne kurz einhaken. Denn ist denn Kaiserslautern wirklich the real deal? Denn ich habe die Zweite-Männer-Bundesliga jetzt immer so auf einem Auge mitlaufen lassen, würde ich mal sagen. So ein Viertel einer Gehirnhälfte haben sie von mir gekriegt. Und da glaube ich, mich zu erinnern, dass Kaiserslautern zwar jetzt nicht unverdient die Punkte geholt hat, die man geholt hat, aber da waren halt auch glückliche Spielverläufe mit dabei. Unter anderem jetzt ja –also am allerbesten konnte man es jetzt am letzten Spieltag sehen –gegen Fürth. Also über Fürth, denke ich, werden wir auch noch ein paar Worte verlieren müssen. Aber dass die nicht aus dieser ersten Hälfte rausgehen und schon deutlicher hinten liegen, das ist eigentlich nicht anders zu erklären als eben mit Zufall. Jetzt meiner Meinung nach. Also kann man dem denn trauen, was da lauter macht? Eva, du wolltest ja gerade auch schon dazwischen gehen.
Ja, also das Führtspiel fällt ein bisschen außerhalb dieser Bewertung. Weil gerade, wie du eben schon gesagt hast, in der ersten Hälfte Führt ja wirklich drückend überlegen war. Aber was zum Beispiel Kaiserslautern in einem Paderborn-Spiel so gut gemacht hat, was sie meiner Meinung nach dann andersherum eher unglücklich hinten raus verloren haben, ist, dass sie da sehr, sehr gut auf den Gegner eingestellt waren. Sie haben Paderborn über weite Phasen der ersten Hälfte überhaupt nicht ihr Spiel entwickeln lassen. Also das Pressing war unfassbar diszipliniert und gut angelegt, gut portioniert. Und man hat dann selber immer mal wieder versucht, eben durchzubrechen. Ich glaube, natürlich profitieren sie durchaus durch glückliche Spielverläufe, wie jetzt zuletzt gegen Führd, eventuell auch im Spiel gegen St. Pauli. Also war schon immer mal wieder da, dass sie durchaus auch, wie gesagt, profitiert haben. Ich meine, direkt am ersten Spieltag kam sie erst Last-Minute, auch das Tor gegen Hannover geschossen. Aber ich finde tatsächlich, es passt irgendwie zu diesem Dirk Schuster-Fußball auch so ein bisschen. Ich habe mich auch daran erinnert, dass er das zweite Mal mit einem Verein in der Relagation von der Dritten in die 2. Liga aussteigt und ja durchaus dann ja doch die Liga ein bisschen aufwirbelt. Weil, wenn ich mich erinnere, war das ja mit Darmstadt auch so. Liebe Grüße an alle Bielefeld-Fans, die freuen sich bestimmt richtig über dieses Relagationsspiel. Da war es ja auch so, dass sie, meine ich, danach durchmarschiert sind in die 1. Liga. Das glaube ich bei Kaiserslautern jetzt nicht, aber dass Dirk Schuster durchaus Überraschungsmomente für sich nutzen kann. Man hat jetzt schon am Wochenende gesehen, dass Durm auf der linken Seite gespielt hat. Und da fühlte er sich, so wie ich das gesehen habe, nicht so wahnsinnig wohl. Kaiserslautern hat in dem Spiel auch das erste Mal tatsächlich die Ausstellung geändert, weil Zuckia im Spiel davor die rote Karte gesehen hat und deshalb umstellen musste. Das hat man durchaus in der ersten Hälfte gesehen. Sie profitieren schon durch Konstanz in der Ausstellung, was natürlich gleichzeitig irgendwann im Laufe der Saison dazu führen kann, dass vielleicht die zweite Reihe sich denkt, ja, wäre jetzt auch schön, wenn wir mal ein bisschen durchtauschen würden. Ist ja schön, wenn das alles so klappt, aber wir wollten auch gerne Spielpraxis haben. Von daher bin ich da mal gespannt, wie das dann aussieht. Aber ich finde schon, dass man durchaus anerkennen kann, dass sie als Aussteiger durchaus einen sehr geordneten Spielaufbau haben, eine sehr ordentliche Idee haben, wie es ums Verteidigen geht. Und dann natürlich auch mit Andreas Lute einen Torhüter haben, der einfach unfassbar erfahren ist und da jetzt in ein paar Spielen noch durchaus gezeigt hat, warum er eben geholt wurde. Und ich glaube, gerade mit Durm und Lute sind halt zwei Spieler vor allem in diesem Kader, wo man jetzt sicher als Erstes gesagt hätte, okay, die wechseln jetzt zu einem Zweite-Liga-Aufsteiger. Und die passen aber ganz gut ins Gefüge. Also ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass sie aufsteigen und dass sie für den Rest der Saison da oben bleiben, aber das sind alles Punkte, die man am Endeffekt erstmal gegen den Abstieg sammelt, um das Plump auszudrücken. Und das machen sie eben sehr gut.
Ja, da würde ich gleich einhaken wollen. Also ich finde auch die Transfers sehr clever. Also mit Durm und Lute, wie du ja schon gerade gesagt hast, hat man dann auch zwei erfahrene Leute geholt. Aber was man bei Kaiserslautern finde ich auch nochmal herausstellen muss, die hatten meiner Meinung nach auch für einen Aufsteiger einen schweren Saisonstart. Hannover kam zuerst, klar kann man sagen, die sind im Umbruch und man wusste jetzt nicht genau, wie diese Mannschaft, die jetzt eigentlich für Hannover-Verhältnisse sich schon sehr gut verstärkt hat, wenn man Spieler für Spieler sich anschaut, die gekommen sind. Aber sie hatten Hannover zu Hause, sie hatten St. Pauli, Paderborn und jetzt Absteiger Greutner Fürth im Anfangsprogramm gehabt und dann schon so viele Punkte zu holen. Natürlich hatte man sehr viel Glück gehabt jetzt in Fürth beim Auswärtsspiel. Aber ich finde, man muss das dann auch wieder loben, dass man das dann halt schafft, diese kritische Phase, dass der Gegner halt wirklich schon gefühlt 5-0 führen müsste. Dass man das übersteht und dass man dann aus der Haltzeit rauskommt und das Spiel erstmal direkt dreht in den ersten Minuten. Und dann auch quasi, ja, das bis zum Schluss verteidigt. Und das zeigt ja auch, dass man ja einen gewissen Zusammenhalt hat, aber auch, dass man mit gewissem Selbstvertrauen schon dabei ist. Und da klaut dann schon mal auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mal ordentlich Punkte gesammelt gegen den Abstieg. Weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass die jetzt bis zum Saisonende oben bleiben. Aber das war auf jeden Fall ein Auftakt, der, finde ich, sehr viel Respekt verdient.
Die zweitwenigsten Schüsse nach Sandhausen pro Spiel, den zweitwenigsten Ballbesitz und die schlechteste Passquote gemeinsam mit Sandhausen. Aber eben sehr gute Ergebnisse, die man daraus holt. Also Kenny Redondo, zwei Tore, Mike Wunderlich, habt ihr ja genannt. Terence Boyd hat auch in der zweiten Liga jetzt schon getroffen. Je war es auch Redondo und Boyd, auch zwei Assists noch dazu. Also das sieht gut aus beim FCK. Jetzt würde ich gerne ein Team kurz überspringen, nämlich den HSV. Lasst uns vielleicht erst noch über Rostock sprechen. Die stehen auf Rang 6, haben dreimal gewonnen, zweimal verloren. War das nicht in der letzten Saison auch schon so, dass sie so entweder verlieren oder gewinnen, Team waren? Ich habe es nicht mehr ganz genau auf der Platte. Aber Tobi, was ist denn zu Rostock zu sagen? Wie haben sie es jetzt erst mal zwischenzeitlich dorthin geschafft? Mit neun Punkten hat man jetzt aktuell sechs Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Es ist allerdings noch ein bisschen früh, um diese Abstände zu rechnen. Aber zumindest der Start ist ja sehr positiv bei Rostock.
Ja, so fußballerisch sieht das bei Hansa schon gut aus. Man muss ja sagen, jetzt die Siege gegen HSV, Samp-Pauli und Bielefeld waren da jetzt auch nicht unbedingt vorhersehbar. Und bei Hansa, muss ich auch sagen, hatte ich vor der Saison meine Zweifel gehabt, weil die mich letztes Jahr schon positiv überrascht hatten. Und das ist ja auch bei Aussteigern, spricht man ja oft vom schweren zweiten Jahr, wo es dann runtergehen könnte. Und wenn ich mir dann aber die Spiele anschaue, auch jetzt zum Beispiel das Auswärtsspiel beim HSV, da war ich auch im Stadion, die wissen halt ganz genau, was sie können. Und das bringen sie auch auf den Platz. Also in Hamburg haben sie geführt, außer einen späten Torschuss von Glatzel, der hätte drin sein müssen, haben sie wenig zugelassen. Hinten sehr dicht gestanden und dann halt die perfekte Konterchance genutzt. So holst du halt in der 2. Liga auch gerne mal die Punkte gegen die Großen. Bei Hansa habe ich das Gefühl, dass auch da eine Stärke, da werden wir wahrscheinlich auch bei Sandhausen später noch zu kommen, dass die sich halt sehr gut einschätzen können und halt auch nur das auf den Platz bringen wollen. Und auch als Verein, wenn es zu sportlichen Entscheidungen kommt, auch das quasi das Beste aus sich rausholen, quasi alles aus sich rausholen und halt auch immer wissen, wo sie herkommen und diese Mischung ist halt gut und bringt einen halt auch dazu, dass die Mannschaft solche Leistungen bringen kann.
Aber wie nachhaltig wird das sein, Eva? Also ich will das jetzt nicht kleinreden, ich habe ja auch sehr wenig von irgendwelchen Rostock-Spielen gesehen. Ich habe mehr Dinge gesehen, die neben dem Platz waren, über die wir sicherlich auch gleich noch kurz sprechen werden. Tobi hat ja auch schon das Sportlich zweimal so betrunken, dass ich glaube, dass das auch schon ein kleiner Wink mit dem braunen Zaunpfahl war. Aber neun Punkte nach fünf Spielen ist natürlich super, kann aber halt auch sein, dass wir jetzt in zehn Spielen dann über Rostock sprechen und dann kamen gar nicht mehr so viele mit dazu. Also das hat man jetzt auch schon häufig genug erlebt, ich will nicht sagen, dass es so kommt. Also gibt es Punkte, wo du sagst, das lässt dich hoffen oder erwarten, dass das jetzt beständig so ist, dass Rostock eben einfach weiter so seine Punkte und seine Dreier einfährt in Spielen, in denen man es auch gar nicht erwartet und sich so dann ja dann möglicherweise wieder in der Liga halten kann?
Was mich so ein bisschen positiv stimmt, ist, dass man zuletzt eben zwei Heimspiele gewonnen hat. Das war so ein bisschen was, was in der letzten Saison nicht so häufig passiert ist. Also, dass man da so ein leichtes Muster gesehen hat, dass eben da so ab und zu so ein bisschen der Mut fehlte, was man auch so jetzt gezeigt hat. Woran das lag, kann ich nicht genau sagen. Wahrscheinlich vor allem auch an den Gegnern, die kamen. Ich fand es dann so ein bisschen ironisch, dass dann beim ersten Heimspiel gegen oder genau am ersten Spieltag gegen Heidenheim, dann eigentlich eine Mannschaft kam, von der wir immer auswärts wissen, die ist jetzt eigentlich nicht so wahnsinnig stark auswärts, die da dann gewinnt. Also es wirkt ja erst am ersten Spieltag wieder so, ah ja, here we go again. Ich fand es dann aber, also ich habe sie ja auch gegen Bielefeld gesehen, natürlich. Zu Bielefeld kommen wir ja später noch, da ist es dann halt auch so, da mussten sie halt gar nicht 90 Minuten lang irgendwie ein Powerplay machen, weil der Gegner halt auch einfach viel zu wenig irgendwie dagegen gehalten hat. Da hat man ja dann gegen Darmstadt gesehen, sobald Rostock dann vielleicht auch mal unter Druck gesetzt wird. Gut, da war auch dieser unfassbar unglückliche Fehler dann von Kolke hinten im Tor, dieser Komplett-Aussetzer irgendwie. Aber also ich glaube schon, dass das Problem bei Rostock sein könnte, wenn sie halt dann mal anfangen hinten ein bisschen auseinanderzubrechen, dann halt richtig. Obwohl sie es natürlich unfassbar gut aufgefangen haben jetzt im Spiegel gegen St. Pauli. Und ich glaube, dass sie gerade spielstarke Mannschaften, die irgendwie einen Plan haben nach vorne, die spielerisch arbeiten wollen, einfach sehr, sehr frustrieren können, weil sie gut dagegenhalten. Ich finde, mit Kai Pröger hat man den Sturm unfassbar gut ergänzt. Er funktioniert ja auch direkt. Ich fand es halt zum Teil letzte Saison mit Verhoog ein wenig einseitig, wo man dann eben auch gesehen hat, wenn er mal ausfiel, dass da vorne einfach was fehlt. Weil der Ersatz oder die Spieler, die das so ein bisschen füllen sollten, das einfach nicht wirklich konnten, weil das ganze Spiel eben auch so auf Verhoog konzentriert war. Und ich finde, das haben sie jetzt einfach diese Saison schon mit Kai Prüger so ein bisschen aufgefangen. Von daher, sportlich gesehen, ziehe ich meinen Hut vor an Saarostdorf. Das ist schon extrem stark, so erstmal noch mal wieder in die Saison zu starten. Wie gesagt, ich glaube, das müssen wir bei Eva allen Vereinen sagen, egal, ob es jetzt im Positiven oder Negativen sind. Man darf es alles nicht so komplett überbewerten. Ich finde, dass durch diese zweieinhalbmonatige Pause, das hattet ihr ja auch in der Rasenfunk-Schluckskonferenz vor dem Start der Männerbundesliga angesprochen, Prognosen ein ganz, ganz schwieriges Ding, weil man einfach nicht weiß, was in diesen zweieinhalb Monaten passieren könnte. Es ist ja wirklich gerade in der zweiten Liga so. Die Pause zwischen 17. und 18. Spieltag ist im Endeffekt länger als die zwischen dem 34. der letzten Saison oder der ersten dieser Saison.
Und die Spieler sind eben wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr im Saft. Das ist noch der Unterschied zur ersten Männerbundesliga. Da haben viele Spieler, nicht alle, bei diesem Turnier und spielen dann noch ein bisschen. In der zweiten Liga muss man darüber nachdenken, wie man den Spielern zwar Urlaub gönnt, aber trotzdem auch Urlaubspläne mitgibt, dass man nicht wieder komplett eine Vorbereitung neu machen muss. Das ist schon ein bisschen bizarr.
Genau, und trotzdem fliegen oder planen superviele Vereine wieder Trainingslager. Was ja eigentlich nichts Ungewöhnliches war. Das war ja vor Corona auch gang und gäbe, weil die Pause da ja eigentlich auch länger war. Zwischen quasi Hin- und Rückrunde, bzw. gerade in der zweiten Liga war es ja oft so, dass die Rückrunde dann auch schon gestartet hat. Aber ich finde es halt super schwierig. Es wird definitiv auch Vereine in der zweiten Liga geben, die von dieser Pause profitieren können. Weil sie vielleicht auch –ich sage jetzt mal –die finanziellen Mittel haben, vielleicht ein, zwei Transfers noch zu tätigen, die vielleicht andere Vereine nicht haben. Aber ich glaube, jetzt zur Bestandsaufnahme macht Rostock das einfach gut, hat vielleicht auch aus ein paar Fehlern der letzten Saison gelernt, wie eben nochmal die Verpflichtung von Kai Prüger. Von daher will ich mir da jetzt erstmal nicht zu große Sorgen machen. Da gibt es immer noch Vereine in der oberen Tabellenhälfte, wo ich da eher nochmal draus schielen würde. Aber wie gesagt, das ist bis jetzt ganz ordentlich.
Zu unseren Prognosen muss man ja auch immer dazu sagen, letztes Jahr zu diesem Zeitpunkt, da waren fünf Spieltagen Dynamo Dresden, glaube ich, vierter oder fünfter und den ersten oder zweiter, die vielleicht sogar abgestiegen wären, wenn die Saison noch vier, fünf Wochen weitergegangen wäre. Die sind ja quasi ins Bodenlose abgestürzt, wo es ja in der Hinrunde teilweise schon bei einigen darum ging, ob die wirklich bis zum Ende oben mitspielen können. Wie gesagt, Hansa macht es bisher gut auf dem Platz.
Propos Bodenlose, kommen wir zu den Sachen neben dem Platz?
Ja, auf dem Platz läuft es, aber was man da wieder an Plakaten oder Bannern sehen musste, da ist es wirklich bodenlos und es ist halt auch nichts Neues bei Hansa.
Ganz kurz bevor du drüber sprichst, ich hole diejenigen rein, die es nicht gesehen haben. Beim Spiel gegen St. Pauli, was ja sowieso ein emotional aufgeladenes Spiel ist, das soll aber nichts rechtfertigen, wirklich in keinster Weise, gab es 30 Jahre nach Rostock-Lichtenhagen ein Lichtenhagen-Plakat, aber nicht mit irgendeiner Botschaft, die sagt, nie wieder, sondern eher mit dem Anschein, da sind wir ein bisschen stolz drauf, dass wir da ein Pokrom in Deutschland nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg noch mal starten konnten. Das war ja auch nicht der einzige dieser Zeit. Und es gab noch ein homo-feindliches Plakat, aber das will ich jetzt nicht wiederholen, weil das war auch wahnsinnig dumm. Beides war natürlich so gemacht, dass man sich unglaublich schlau fühlen kann, wenn man zu den Holbern gehört, die das gemacht haben, nämlich weil de facto stand da nichts Verwerfliches drauf. Das war nicht justiziabel. Auch Nazis sind heutzutage nicht mehr dumm. Aber es war so extrem geschmacklos. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt zum ersten Mal aus Teilen der Fanszene von Rostock sowas zu sehen ist. Also das war quasi das, was zu sehen war. Sorry, jetzt habe ich sogar schon ein bisschen angefangen, mich rein zu... Aber mich lässt das Emotionalen nicht kalt. Ich wollte nur kurz alle hören und höre, die es nicht mitbekommen haben. Um diese Plakate geht es. Tobi, jetzt darfst du wieder übernehmen.
Ja, ich kann eigentlich wieder bei dem Wort bodenlos anknüpfen. Also solche Leute haben oder Leute, die solche Banner aufhängen oder selbst zusehen und es quasi abnicken, dass man sowas aufhängt, haben im Stadion nichts zu suchen. Und ja, sollte man auch verurteilen. In dem Fall hast du ja aber gesagt, es ist nicht justiziabel, was dort aufgehangen wurde. Aber das, was da als Botschaft, als nicht draufstehende Botschaft mitschwingt, ist von einer ganz üblen Sorte. Und es ist halt in dem Sinne schade, dass sich Hansa ja auch in dem Sinne ja, fast auch selber, oder nicht nur fast, sich selbst ins Bein schießt, weil es halt gerade sportlich läuft. Und man denkt, okay, man kann jetzt eigentlich, man ist seit Jahren in der dritten Liga, erst mal wieder in der zweiten Liga, kann jetzt sportlich auf sich aufmerksam machen, es hat einen guten Saisonstart, und dann reißen die Fans, wenn wir die Fans nennen wollen, reißen das wieder quasi das ganze positive Bild, was man sich da aufbaut, auf dem Platz wieder ein. Es ist ja auch leider nicht das erste Mal, dass man solche Sachen bei Hansa im Stadion sieht, beziehungsweise bei den Zuschauern. Und ja, es beschädigt halt das Bild von Hansa, aber auch von den Leuten, die da wirklich im Stadion sind. Und auch von den Leuten, die nicht dazu stehen und das selber verurteilen, Hansa Trikots anhaben, aber in dem Sinne machtlos sind dagegen.
Genau, und da will ich auf jeden Fall auch noch einhaken. Ich habe tatsächlich den Vorfall auch nur durch einen Tweet einer Rostockerin mitbekommen, die sich ganz klar davon distanziert hat und eben die Problematik angesprochen hat, dass es einfach in der eigenen Fanszene auch sofort relativiert wird. Also zu sagen, dass das einfach nur provozierend gemeint und das ist nicht so. Und wo sie eben auch ganz klar sagt, ich möchte mit euch nichts zu tun haben, ist ehrlich gesagt, blieb es ja auch nicht nur nach den Bannern. Es gibt Videos von vor oder nach dem Spiel der Rostocker, wo Schlachtgesänger auch in eine ganz bestimmte Richtung gehen, die ich jetzt so auch wirklich nicht wiederholen möchte. Aber es ist halt wirklich immer schade, weil natürlich ist das nicht –also sind das nicht alle Fans. Ich habe mich da so ein bisschen eingelesen, ein bisschen geschaut. Es ist eben wohl wirklich ein Blog, den man zwischendurch auch aus dem Stadion raus hatte, der sich aber irgendwie jetzt auch wieder mit reingezogen hat. Wo aber natürlich halt –das lässt sich immer leicht sagen –aber natürlich darf sowas dann eben auch vom Rest der Fans gerade auf den Stehtribünen nicht geduldet werden. Und man muss eben dafür sorgen, dass solche Banner einfach nicht irgendwie hochgezogen werden. Das ist natürlich immer leichter gesagt als getan, aber man wünscht es sich natürlich trotzdem. Ich habe jetzt gelesen, dass der DFB auch ermittelt und wegen dieser Banner und eben auch Rostock zu einer Stellungnahme bittet. Rostock hat ja auch durchaus irgendwie ein paar prominente Fans, die sich auch gerne irgendwie mit dem Verein ablichten, wo man sich dann natürlich auch irgendwie wünscht, dass da so eine gewisse Distanzierung folgt. Und ja, von daher, es tut mir wirklich auch leid für die restlichen Rostock-Fans. Das ist wirklich so, weil ich glaube, dass das einfach auch total beschissen ist, wenn man eben dieses Gedankengut überhaupt nicht heilt und einfach nicht mit denen in einen Topf geschmissen werden kann. Von daher hoffe ich, dass da auch der Verein vernünftig reagiert und dass man dann auch in Rostock wirklich nicht immer nur das Sportliche betonen muss, sondern einfach vom ganzen Verein sprechen kann.
Also das mit den prominenten Stimmen, das ist was, was ich nie im Kopf zusammen bekomme, dass jemand wie Materia Rostock-Fan ist und ich dann aber –also zumindest habe ich da noch nichts gesehen von ihm, was überhaupt nicht passt, oder Monchi von Feine seine Fischfilet, wobei der jetzt mit ganz anderen Vorwürfen zu tun hat. Keiner muss Täter sein auf Instagram, falls es euch interessiert, oder niemand muss Täter sein. Ich weiß nicht, ihr werdet es vermutlich finden. Könnt ihr euch noch mal angucken. Aber ich glaube, da möchte ich nur einmal kurz einen Gedanken noch ergänzen. Wir werden das Problem jetzt auch nicht lösen können, aber der Fußball glaube ich, muss an einen Punkt kommen, an dem er auch anerkennt, mit einem Verdrängen von Nazis. Ich nenne sie jetzt einfach so, gibt auch glaube ich wenig Gründe, die dagegen sprechen, sie so zu nennen. Mit einem Verdrängen von Nazis, das wird halt nichts verändern. Denn du kannst Stadionverbote aushängen, du kannst temporär Menschen aus den Blöcken herausbekommen, sie werden aber immer wieder zurückkommen. Das eigentliche Problem liegt natürlich viel tiefer und das eigentliche Problem kommt auch nicht genuin aus dem Fußball, sondern es kommt aus der Gesellschaft. Und ich frage mich, wann wir endlich mal in der Diskussion beim Engagement gegen Rassismus, gegen Diskriminierung, mal da ansetzen, am einzigen Punkt, wo auch die Studienlage aus wissenschaftlicher, aus soziologischer Sicht sagt, da kann man etwas verändern mit viel, viel Zeit und das ist halt in Jugendarbeit. Und da musst du Geld für in die Hand nehmen, du musst Fanprojekte unterstützen. Im Grunde ist jede symbolische Aktion zwar wichtig, weil die Symbolik braucht es auch, wir müssen uns auch immer wieder positionieren, aber manchmal frage ich mich schon, wann kommt denn die DFL mal auf den Trichter zu sagen, hey, von den vielen Milliarden, die wir einnehmen, und es sind ja Milliarden, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal eine Millionensumme in die Hand und unterstützen an Bundesligastandorten ganz gezielt solche Dinge. Und behandeln zum Beispiel auch die Fanprojekte nicht so nachrangig, wie sie behandelt werden, denn die haben eben da eine Wirkung, eine Wirkung, die ganz schwer messbar ist und die vor allem erst in der Zukunft wirkbar wird. There's no glory in prevention. Wir haben es ja jetzt alle während Corona gelernt, wie schwierig das ist, sowas dann auch politisch zu verkaufen, also quasi als verbandspolitisch in dem Fall. Aber warum wird da nicht angesetzt? Man weiß, das ist das Einzige, dass du quasi verhindern kannst, dass diese vermeintlich einfachen Antworten, oder es sind ja einfache Antworten auf komplexe Fragen unserer Zeit und auf Ängste und Sorgen und so weiter, die viele Menschen betreffen, dass die verfangen. Das geht nur mit eben Gegenangeboten, die du schaffst. Und die kosten Geld. Auf diesen Trichter muss jetzt mal langsam gekommen werden. Denn mit Symbolik und mit –selbst sollte es da jetzt Stadionverbote geben, was ich mir ehrlicherweise kaum vorstellen kann, bei der Art und Weise, wie diese Plakate formuliert waren. Das hat ja nichts geholfen. Dann stehen die Leute vorm Stadion und sind genau solche Rassisten. Das macht es ja nicht besser. Es ist schwierig und extrem frustrierend. Das hat zum Rostock Part noch mit dazu gehört. Wir mussten darüber noch sprechen. Jetzt müssen wir irgendwie wieder versuchen, die Kurve zum Sportlichen zu bekommen. Wir haben vor der Sendung noch kurz diskutiert, wo wir den HSV einordnen. Wir konnten uns nicht ganz einigen, ob zwischen positive Überraschung und negative Überraschung. Deswegen kommt jetzt etwas komplett Überraschendes. Aber es passt auch zu diesem Verein. Wir reden ganz kurz über Sandhausen. Denn Eva hat gesagt, ich muss über Sandhausen reden. Und da möchte ich dich fragen, Eva, bei zwei Siegen aus fünf Spielen, damit sechs Punkten und zwischendurch Platz 14, was ist denn daran überhaupt überraschend an Sandhausen? Wir wissen doch, dass die großen Mannschaften Bein stellen. Ist das nicht einfach alles wie immer? Und dann gewinnen sie halt auch mal gegen Bielefeld zum Beispiel. Sorry, Ju.
Ich glaube halt, ich wollte Sandhausen ein bisschen reinbringen, weil ich ein bisschen überrascht war vor der Saison, wie viele sie wieder als direkten Absteiger irgendwie getippt haben. Und ja, ich weiß, Platz 14 ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die so ganz, ganz weit weg von den Abstiegsplätzen. Aber ich finde halt trotzdem das irgendwie immer wieder überraschend, dass Sandhausen, wenn ein Leute nicht einfällt, wen sie als Absteiger tippen sollen, wie immer als erstes Sandhausen da mit drin landet. Vor allem gerade diese Saison, weil ich einfach, wenn man diese Rückrunde nimmt, hat Sandhausen da trotz irgendwie 40 neuer Spieler und 40 weggegangenen Spieler gefühlt einfach, ja, da ist geschafft Ruhe reinzubringen und wirklich diesen Umbruch zu überstehen, was vielen Vereinen ja wirklich schon das Genick gebrochen haben, dass sie eben viele Spieler weggängen, nicht kompensieren konnten und dann zu lange gebraucht haben, das zu ersetzen. Und ich finde halt, klar hat man zuletzt zwei Spiele verloren, aber trotzdem, ja, natürlich ist es irgendwie der Aloe-Schwarz-Fußball, aber ich wollte halt irgendwie kurz meine Lanze für den SV Sandhausen brechen, weil ich einfach, ja, die das einfach über weite Phasen der Saison immer doch sehr intelligent machen. Ich habe ja die Kinsombie-Brüder auch gegen Bielefeld gesehen. Ich finde, es macht irgendwie auch Spaß, den beiden beim Fußballspiel zuzugucken. Die ergänzen sich einfach sehr gut. Vorne jemand wie Kothutschu, der sich jetzt langsam auch einfindet, der ja schon ausgeliehen war letzte Saison. Und ich einfach nicht glaube, dass wir Sandhausen dann wirklich diese Saison über weite Strecken im Abstiegskampf sehen werden, weil die irgendwie, glaube ich, noch mehr als sonst in WG natürlich auch immer durch andere Vereine profitieren. Aber ich finde halt einfach, dass über die immer so ein bisschen einfach abfällig geredet wird. Was ich, ja klar, ist immer so ein bisschen die Hema, aber ich finde halt einfach, dass da viel auch richtig gemacht wird, dass die viele richtige Mechanismen dann doch irgendwie haben, die funktionieren und die greifen, auch wenn es dann zum 1000. Mal gefühlt aloe schwarz ist. Aber gut, ja, und ich einfach doch finde, dass sie das trotzdem im Weggang von Test-Rot bis jetzt ganz ordentlich machen, trotz, ja, trotz nur zwei Sieger und einigen anderen.
Da würde ich sogar zustimmen und würde die zweite Lanze für die brechen und auch sagen, was Sandhausen macht, gefällt mir, weil die, das hatte ich ja schon bei anderen Teams gesagt, die wissen halt einfach, wo sind ihre Möglichkeiten und wo können sie ihre Vorteile noch ziehen daraus, dass sie halt einer dieser vermeintlichen kleinen Vereine der Liga sind. Und allein, wenn man jetzt schon sieht, wie sie, wo du ja eben auch schon Kinzombie angesprochen hast, die Kinzombie-Brüder, wenn ich jetzt die ersten Spiele David Kinzombie gesehen habe, da kann ich meinen Augen gar nicht trauen. Der war beim HSV zuletzt nur noch behebig und quasi Bankspieler und es kam wenig bis gar keine Impulse, wenn er mal eingewechselt wurde und dann siehst du den wirklich über den Platz sprinten und teilweise fast schon Flügelspieler spielen. Und das ist halt, glaube ich, auch so dieses Sandhausen-Ding, was auch Diegmeier ja auch schon gesagt hat. Man hat quasi keinen Druck, hat da ein entspanntes Leben, aber einen Fußballverein, der gar nicht so in der Öffentlichkeit steht, auf dem man sich, wo man sich wirklich auf Fußball konzentrieren kann. Und ich finde auch, Sandhausen wird auch oft viel zu negativ gesehen. Es ist ja auch, wenn ein großer Verein absteigt, dann kommen ja auch die ganzen Fans mit der Hebe. Ja, nächstes Jahr musst du nach Sandhausen, hahaha. Aber ich würde mir dann im Vergleich die Frage stellen, ist jetzt Sandhausen –vom Image, das, was sie zeigen –sind sie in Anführungsstrichen farbloser als Heidenheim? Die meiner Meinung nach vom Verein relativ ähnlich sind, vom Standing, aber über die kann man eigentlich recht wenig sagen, außer dass der Trainer schon seit x Jahren dabei ist und sie immer eigentlich erfolgreich sind. Aber sonst gibt einem der Verein, glaube ich, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehne, mit meiner Meinung auch relativ wenig. Und ich finde, Sandhausen hat eigentlich relativ gut gemacht, meiner Meinung nach, dass man dieses Underdog-Image auch so auf eine sympathische Ebene bringt.
Also sie sind natürlich farbloser als Heidenheim, aber das hat zunächst mal mit den Vereinsfarben zu tun. Und mit diesem –Wow! Ja, Entschuldigung Eva, irgendwas muss ich auch zu diesem Podcast beitragen.
Hab ich dir mal eine gute Vorlage gegeben.
Ja, allerdings. Ich muss nämlich wahnsinnig zurückhalten, dich nicht zu unterbrechen. Das wird jetzt vielleicht auch so, wenn wir über den HSV sprechen wollen, denn den HSV, da wollen wir jetzt logischerweise auch mal ein bisschen ausführlicher drauf gucken, der steht eben zwischen den Welten, so fast so ein bisschen typisch für den HSV. Hätte man die Partie gegen Darmstadt jetzt zuhause nicht in auch dramatischer Art und Weise, da gab es viele Platzverweise, viel Aufregung, mit 1 zu 2 verloren, dann wären wir vielleicht am HSV als sportlicher positiver Überraschung kaum vorbeigekommen. So steht der HSV immerhin bei 9 Punkten nach 5 Spieltagen. Das kann man auch sehr leicht ins Positive verargumentieren. Neben dem Platz ist jetzt allerdings auch viel passiert. Also nicht nur, dass man sich von Uwe Seeler verabschieden muss, sondern ich rede natürlich von den Vorgängen rund um Wüst und Kühne. Da gibt es wieder Angebote. Immer wenn im Kicker fast täglich ein Artikel von Sebastian Wolf zum HSV erscheint, dann ist das eigentlich kein gutes Zeichen, wenn man so ehrlich ist. Und deswegen, Tobias, haben wir sie so ein bisschen zwischen den Welten eingeordnet. Womit willst du denn anfangen, jetzt mit dem Blick auf den HSV, wenn du uns einfach mal auf Stand bringst? Was ist gerade so los in Hamburg?
Na, ist eigentlich sogar recht schwierig zu sagen. Ich habe ja auch schon hier, bevor wir angefangen haben, gesagt, dass ich auch Schwierigkeiten habe, die Saison bisher einzuordnen. Da, wie du sagst, es gibt positive, negative Sachen. Also ich soll es auch sehr positiv empfinde. Und ich glaube, da spreche ich auch vielen Fans aus dem Herzen, dass man es jetzt endlich mal geschafft hat nach einer Saison, die dann auch ihre Höhen und Tiefen hat, aber wieder mit einem großen Tief, damit der Heimliederlage gegen Hertha geendet ist, dass man mal gesagt hat, okay, wir verzichten jetzt mal auf unseren Standardreflex und schmeißen den Trainer raus und schmeißen alle raus und fangen nochmal neu an. In dem Sinne Tim Walther sehr beliebt bei den Fans und auch Jonas Boldt. Man hat auch das Gefühl, und das wird ja auch demonstriert von den beiden, dass sie sehr auch hintereinander stehen und zusammenhalten. Der Fußball unter Walther ist auch eigentlich meiner Meinung nach auch positiv zu bewerten, weil es halt nicht dieses von vielen Vereinen standardisierte –wir stellen uns erstmal hinten rein, gucken und versuchen dann schnell nach vorne zu kommen –sondern es ist halt mutig ballorientiert oder ballbesitzorientiert und repräsentiert auch ein bisschen auch seine Haltung, der ja auch –also Tim Walther, der ja auch –was ihn mit Jonas Boldt eint, auch von den Kameras halt auch sehr selbstsicher einen eindrucksabgeben will. Also in dem Sinne läuft das jetzt eigentlich sportlich gar nicht so schlecht. Man ist auch –mit einem Punkt steht man jetzt besser da als in der letzten Saison, wenn man das vergleicht. Und man hat wieder bisher wenige Tore bekommen, drei Tore, auch wenn man jetzt gegen Braunschweig vielleicht, wenn man sagt, die erste halbe Stunde hätte man schon 3-0 zurücklegen können. Aber es ist eigentlich, würde ich sagen, grundsätzlich schon eher positiv. Aber es ist, wie man den HSV kennt, natürlich auch so, dass das Umfeld nicht lange ruhig bleibt. Und selbst wenn man die Fans mittlerweile, denen man ja früher vorgeworfen hat, dass sie immer nach jedem Sieg wieder in die Champions League wollen oder Europa League hier und da, obwohl man auf Platz 12 ist und eins nicht. Die Fans hat man eigentlich in den letzten Jahren gut zur Demut erzogen quasi. Aber das Umfeld bzw. dann teilweise jetzt selbst Mitarbeiter oder Vereinspräsidenten wie Marcel Janssen, Finanzvorstand Thomas Wüstefeld, Klaus-Michel Kuenes, kommen immer irgendwelche Personen um den Verein herum oder in den Verein, die dann auf einmal wieder Zepter an sich reißen und für negative Stimmung sorgen bzw. für Streit sorgen. Das zieht auch den Verein und dann auch wiederum die Fans wieder ein bisschen runter. Man kann es beim HSV quasi nicht trennen, diese sportliche und die Strukturprobleme, wenn ich sie mal so benennen will. Das lässt einen auch immer dazu zweifeln, wie man jetzt das aktuelle Bild sieht. Weil man siegt 2-0 in Bielefeld, meiner Meinung nach recht souverän und hat dann gleich wieder unter der Woche wieder Punkte, wo es darum geht, wie es geht mit dem Stadionkredit weiter, wird einem die EM entzogen und wieder Streit zwischen Jansen, Wüstefeld, Kühne. Kühne macht ein Angebot, dann macht er ein zweites Angebot gemacht. Man verliert gegen Darmstadt wieder mit sehr viel Hektik im Stadion. Der HFV ist und bleibt einfach ein Pulverfass, das jede Sekunde hochgehen kann. Das ist sehr schwer mit einzuberechnen für alle Beteiligten im Verein.
Darf ich mal versuchen –und ich werde daran scheitern –grob zusammenzufassen, was passiert ist? Weil es vielleicht auch höhere Noteure gibt, an denen das so vorbeigelaufen ist. Und da musst du bitte dazwischengrätschen, wenn ich Fehler mache. Unter anderem habe ich ja nicht Wüstefeld gesagt, sondern einfach nur Wüst. Da fängt es ja schon mal an beim Herrn Ost. Ich würde sagen, zumindest bei mir sind wieder so außersportliche Turbulenzen angekommen beim HSV. Als berichtet wurde, dass es einen Darlehen gab, der Stadt Hamburg an den HSV, für Renovierungsarbeiten bzw. Umbauarbeiten im Zuge der Europameisterschaft, der Männer-Europameisterschaft 2024, dass nicht dafür eingesetzt wurde, sondern um Corona-Lücken zu stopfen, so hatte ich mir das gemerkt. Wie gesagt, du schreist einfach halt falsch, wenn es falsch ist. Okay, so traurig das ist, aber bisher ist es richtig. Zudem ist mit Thomas Wüstefeld ein Investor eingestiegen im Oktober 2021. Der hat so ein bisschen mehr als fünf Prozent der AG-Anteile gekauft. Für rund 14 Millionen war das, glaube ich, so ungefähr der Deal. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt überhaupt daher kommt jetzt erst mal dieser Unternehmer, dieser Name, deswegen ist der jetzt auch beim HSV mit aktiv. Der hat sich kritisch gegenüber Kühne geäußert. Kühne, der im letzten Jahr, ich glaube im August oder so, hat Kühne doch gesagt, ich habe jetzt mit dem HSV abgeschlossen und ich lasse dir jetzt in Ruhe alles machen und ich wünsche dem HSV alles Gute. Der hat diesen Vorsatz insofern eingehalten, dass er sich jetzt ständig wieder zu Wort meldet und angesichts der aktuellen Finanzlage angeboten hat, ein Darlehen zu gewähren, mit dem aber Bedingungen verknüpft sind, wie z.B. dass andere Investoren nicht mitreden dürfen. Damit kann er ja nur Wüstefeld meinen. Es sind noch so Zuckerli dabei, wie dass man das Stadion in Uwe Seeler Arena benennen würde, also nach Uwe Seeler, aber es wäre eben dann doch wieder das, was wir beim HSV wieder und wieder gesehen haben, nämlich dass mit Klaus-Michał Kühne jemand, der nicht aus dem Sport kommt, doch auf eine Art und Weise mitredet, die ins Sportliche mindestens hineinstrahlt, um es jetzt mal ganz zurückhaltend zu formulieren. Und dann gab es auch noch einen Arbeitsprozess, und da habe ich es jetzt schon wieder vergessen. Ich weiß nur, dass da herauskam, dass auch das Verhältnis zwischen Wüstefeld und Bolt, glaube ich, nicht so gut sein soll. Und gleichzeitig –ah ja, da entmuted er sich schon, der Tobias, gleich geht es los. Und gleichzeitig, letzter Satz von mir, dann darfst du alles korrigieren. Gleichzeitig gibt es auch noch eine personelle Verbindung zwischen Wüstefeld und Marcel Jansen. Marcel Jansen ist ja Präsident des HSV. Thomas Wüstefeld ist ein Medizinunternehmer, der hat verkauft unter anderem so PCR-Testkits. Und Marcel Jansen hat wohl Wüstefeld angeblich, ich glaube, das hat der Spiegel recherchiert, dabei geholfen, die auch im Fußballbereich zu verkaufen. Also an Bundesligavereine zum Beispiel, da hat er Kontakte hergestellt. Das heißt, es gäbe eben auch ein persönliches, vielleicht sogar ein wirtschaftliches Band zwischen den beiden. Ich glaube, Jansen sitzt sogar in irgendeinem Holding von Wüstefeld mit drin. Was vielleicht auch erklären würde, dass Marcel Jansen vielleicht auch kein neutraler Akteur ist, wenn er eben als Präsident über Kühne über Wüstefeld spricht. Oh Gott, ich bin jetzt schwitzen gekommen, Tobi.
Ja, ich würde dir gerne ein Handtuch reichen, aber es wird nicht besser. Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht der, muss ich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt zugeben, nicht der allergrößte Experte, was da die ganzen Strukturen angeht. Aber es ist halt, wie du sagst, es kommen Leute von außen in den Verein rein. Auch jetzt so ein Wüstefeld, der sich Anteile gekauft hat, auch sagt, er ist seit gefühlt 100 Jahren HSV-Fan. Er musste Anteile kaufen oder hat sie jetzt von Kühne abgekauft, wurde dann in den HSV reingeholt von Jansen, der ja, wie du schon gesagt hast, hinter dieser ganzen Fußballgeschichte mit ihm verbunden ist, wirtschaftlich bzw. beruflich. Es soll auch mehrere Spenden von Wüstefeld geben zu Projekten, wo Marcel Jansen auch involviert ist. Und jetzt ist er ja auch quasi zu diesen Posten des Finanzvorstands gekommen. Und es ist halt bisher so, jetzt relativ leicht gesagt, dass man Jansen und Wüstefeld auf einer Seite sehen muss und Tim Walter und Jonas Boldt, die zusammen auf einer Seite stehen und sich quasi gegenseitig mehr oder weniger, wenn ich es jetzt mal so plump sagen will, aus dem Verein rauszukriegen. Es wird aber vermutet, dass Jansen und Wüstefeld eigentlich die sportliche Leitung beiderseits austauschen wollen, während Jansen und Wüstefeld von sehr vielen Leuten kritisiert werden und auch Boldt quasi, um beim HSV bleiben zu können, sich den kleinen Attacken Wüstefeld wehren muss. Es ist auch das offene Geheimnis, dass die sich auch nicht verstehen, wobei sie dann vor der Kamera natürlich wieder gute Mine zum bösen Spiel machen. Und ja, mit Kühne ist es auch so eine Sache, der ja, wie du schon gesagt hast, mehrmals gesagt hat, er lässt jetzt quasi die Finger vom HSV, weil er damit abgeschlossen hat. Das hat er ja auch übrigens nach dem Abstieg direkt mehr oder weniger gesagt und ist immer wieder zurückgekommen. Und jetzt hat er halt wieder ein Angebot gemacht, um weitere Anteile zu bekommen, wo aber die Mitgliederversammlung zustimmen müsste. Und das Angebot von Kühne würde meiner Meinung nach niemals von den Mitgliedern befürwortet werden. Also war es in meinen Augen auch wieder so ein Angebot nach dem Motto, ich weiß, dass es dem HSV schlecht geht, ich mache jetzt ein Angebot, um mehr Macht zu haben, weiß aber eigentlich, dass das nicht angenommen werden kann, um aber dann öffentlich so dazustehen, dass ich sagen kann, okay, ich habe dem HSV die Hand gereicht und man will meine Hilfe nicht. Jetzt hat er gestern ein zweites Angebot gemacht, wo er schon dem Verein wieder ein bisschen hingekommen ist, wo er quasi die Macht, die er im ersten Versuch gefordert hat, wieder ein bisschen zurückgeschraubt hat, sodass der HSV jetzt gesagt hat, okay, wir gehen in Gespräche. Aber wie das alles ausgehen wird, ist völlig offen, weil meiner Meinung nach auch Alteimer Sir Jansen beispielsweise nicht wirklich fest im Sattel sitzt. Also kann es sein, dass jetzt bald wieder Deals verkündet werden, wo ein paar Wochen später wieder die entscheidenden Akteure wieder weg sein werden.
Also wir werden das jetzt auch nicht ändern können oder noch tiefer besprechen, weil da gibt es quasi laufende Berichterstattung zu. Aber das ist quasi der aktuelle Stand wie beim Hamburger SV. Es bleibt einfach so, wie es ist beim HSV. Und alle Fans können da einem nur Leid tun. Also nicht nur, dass man irgendwie mit Uwe Seeler, einen der sympathischsten Menschen aus dem Fußballbetrieb Deutschlands, verloren hat, sondern jetzt kommt das alles auch noch mit dazu. Also ich will es natürlich nicht nebeneinander stellen, aber es steht ja in einem chronologischen Zusammenhang. Den möchte ich damit hervorheben. Es ist der HSV. Tobi, ich glaube, wir werden darüber auch noch öfter hier im Rasenfunk reden. Ich glaube, weil wir haben uns ja auch ein zeitliches Ziel gesetzt, deswegen würde ich fast vorschlagen, Nürnberg überspringen wir. Wir sind jetzt quasi aus der positiven Zone über die neutrale Zone, als wir jetzt eher bei den negativen Überraschungen nach fünf Spieltagen gelandet. Nürnberg können wir vielleicht auch deshalb überspringen, denn über die werden wir auch reden müssen. Dieter Hecking hat nämlich jetzt erst angekündigt, in zwei Wochen würde er sagen, ob er denn weitermachen will als Sportdirektor beim FCN. Da gab es verschiedene Gründe, warum er da doch noch mal ins Wanken geraten ist. Er hat gesagt, es ist eine Lösung für beide Seiten. Gut ist er aber gleichzeitig auch in der Vergangenheit, in der jüngeren Vergangenheit angedeutet, vielleicht doch wieder auf die Trainerbank zurückkehren zu wollen. Also ich habe da irgendwie das Gefühl, beim Club wird sich auch noch was tun. Deswegen würde ich jetzt sagen, um die machen wir jetzt einfach mal eine Klammer und kommen zu den richtigen Enttäuschungen nach fünf Spieltagen bzw. negativen Überraschungen. Ich glaube, so deutlich muss man es formulieren. Und da müssen wir, Eva, bevor wir gleich länger mit dir noch über Bielefeld sprechen, definitiv auch über den zweiten Absteiger sprechen, nämlich die Spielvereinigung Greuther Fürth bzw. Spielvereinigung Fürth, wenn es nach vielen Menschen in Fürth gehen wird. Jede Meldung dazu wird mir zugeschickt, nicht nur von Michael. Also ich versuche es auf dem Schirm zu haben. Fürth hat nach fünf Spieltagen noch keinen Sieg, Eva, 6 zu 10 Tore, 3 unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen. Was ist los bei den Kleeblättern?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, das Problem ist vor allem, dass sie gefühlt einfach zu wenig Tore schießen. Also aus ihren Möglichkeiten oder aus ihren Chancen zu wenig machen. Ich glaube, dafür ist wirklich Kaiserslautern leider einfach das Paradebeispiel. Wenn man sich da einfach mal anguckt, was es in der ersten Halbzeit für Chancen gab, auch ehrlich gesagt noch in der zweiten Halbzeit zum Ende hin. Ache, der irgendwie drei Chancen hintereinander weg hatte und was dann alles aber auch ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so richtig geordnet war. Man stand eben unter Zeitdruck und man musste jetzt eigentlich auch mal treffen. Ja, dass da einfach ganz, ganz viel unglücklich läuft. Ich glaube, es hat bestimmt auch was damit zu tun, dass man eben zu viel unentschieden spielt. Also in Spielen, wo man ja vielleicht auch vorne war. Man bekommt es eben nicht, über 90 Minuten hin konzentriert zu arbeiten. Ich glaube, dass durchaus auch so ein bisschen die ungewisse Zukunft noch von Branimigo Guter ein bisschen im Raum steht. Also bleibt er, bleibt er nicht. Er hat ja gerade zuletzt gegen Düsseldorf ja auch gezeigt, dass er eben wichtig für den Verein ist, weil er eben die wichtigen Tore macht, weil er einfach sehr viel im Spielaufbau, im Kreatieren von Chancen mit eingebunden ist und natürlich einfach schon zuviert gehört, die natürlich mit Nielsen als einer der Topspieler und eben Stefan Leitel schon zwei sehr wichtige Personen verloren haben. Wenn man es natürlich mit Amina vergleicht, machen sie zumindest eine Sache besser. Sie schießen ein paar Tore mehr und verlieren nicht ganz so viele Spiele, aber sie gewinnen eben auch die Spiele nicht. Ich glaube, das ist eben genau das, was beide Absteiger auch angesprochen haben, dass es unfassbar schwierig sein wird, in dieser Liga anzukommen. Das sieht man eben, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr, als sie sich beide gewünscht hätten. Es kommt ja tatsächlich zum Duell jetzt am Wochenende auch zwischen Ex-Trainer und Ex-Verein bei Hannover 96, wo ich noch überhaupt nicht sagen möchte, wie es laufen wird, weil Hannover ist halt ehrlich gesagt auch Hannover, da kann auch alles passieren. Ich glaube, da könnte man auch eine, weiß ich nicht, achtheilige Romanreihe drüber schreiben, was bei Hannover alles so neben dem Platz ganz hervorragend läuft. Nee, aber es ist natürlich so in der 2. Liga, Achtung, Floskel, es ist kein Spiel leicht, aber es ist natürlich einfach, man weiß, man hat ein paar gute Spiele unentschieden gegen Düsseldorf zu holen, das ist natürlich nicht schlecht, gegen Karlsruhe, ich weiß nicht, aber es ist halt einfach, es fehlt einfach ein bisschen zu viel, glaube ich, diese Idee, wo man hin will. Wie gesagt, man erarbeitet sich durchaus Chancen. Ich finde zum Beispiel jemand wie Ache sehr interessant vorne drin. Ich finde, man kann durchaus sehen, was zum Teil auch unter Marc Schneider ein Ziel sein könnte, aber das bringen sie eben zu wenig auf den Rasen und das bringen sie vor allem nicht konsequent genug dafür, dass man dann hinten einfach nicht stabil genug steht. Das war natürlich am Wochenende vielleicht am Ende ein bisschen zu hohes Ergebnis, das 3 zu 1, aber es war natürlich so, wenn ich dann irgendwann hinten relativ offen stehe, kommt auch eine Mannschaft wie Kaiserslautern und Konterdalt einfach intelligent. Aber es ist sowohl Asta als auch Ache jetzt am Wochenende waren halt so ein bisschen die Unglücksrahmen, weil sie glaube ich wirklich unfassbar, man soll ja endlich nicht von 100%igen sprechen, aber einfach sehr, sehr gute Chancen für Fürth nicht verwandelt haben. Und das trägt dann natürlich nicht dazu bei, dass man sich in der Situation da gerade gut rauskämpfen kann. Und ja, ich muss auch gestehen, ich glaube, man weiß, auch da gibt es natürlich zur Verbindung zu Bielefeld, aber man weiß irgendwie noch nicht so ganz, wo für Marc Schneider steht. Also ich muss auch gestehen, ich habe kein Spiel von Fürth in voller Länge gesehen, aber halt immer die Zusammenfassung und Co. und drüber gesprochen. Aber ich weiß noch nicht so ganz, wo Marc Schneider hingehen will. Ich finde, es ist zum Teil sehr unkoordiniert, was auch irgendwie im Mittelfeld. Und dann vorne passiert. Und ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, also Michi könnte uns da bestimmt mehr zu erzählen. Aber ja, ich habe da irgendwie noch ein paar Fragezeichen.
Tobi, magst du da was ergänzen?
Ich würde es gerne kurz halten. Hatten viel Pech in den Spielen, haben einen jungen Kader. Und wenn sie wie Versagt vom Tor keilschnäuziger werden und jetzt auch mal in den nächsten Wochen ein, zwei Siege holen werden, dann wird es auch relativ schnell wieder Richtung oberes Drittel gehen. Ob es dann letztendlich dann wirklich 5, 6 oder vielleicht dann sogar 7, 8 wird, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt nur eine schwierige Phase mit einer jungen Mannschaft.
Gut, dann stellt sich die Frage, wie schnell Arminia Bielefeld wieder den Anschluss nach oben finden wird. Also wenn man auf die letzten vier Tabellenplätze aktuell nach fünf Spieltagen blickt, dann haben wir da eben 4 auf 15 mit drei Punkten, Magdeburg auf 16 mit drei Punkten, Braunschweig auf 18 mit einem Punkt und mitten zwischen den Aufsteigern eben Arminia Bielefeld, Eva mit einem Punkt und einem neuen Trainer, Uli Forte durfte nur vier Spiele an der Seitenlinie von Arminia Bielefeld stehen bzw. im Pflichtspiel sind es dann wahrscheinlich fünf. Was ist da los bei der Arminia? Warum hat das so gar nicht funktioniert mit ihm? Wie siehst du diesen frühen Trainerwechsel? Man hat ja auch den Nachfolger schon gefunden. Daniel Schanning von Osnabrück kommt zu Bielefeld.
Ja, ich glaube, das Problem war einfach so ein bisschen, dass Uli Forte dann nicht damit gerechnet hat, dass es so früh in der Saison schon einen Negativlauf gibt. Und er hat selber gesagt, sowas hat er noch nie erlebt, also dass es eben so, auf gut Deutsch gesagt, beschissen startet. Und ich glaube, der hatte einfach keine Antwort dafür, was halt so ein bisschen schade war, weil also, ich weiß, man sollte Testspiele nie überbewerten, aber man sieht ja zum Teil Dinge in den Testspielen, wo man denkt, okay, natürlich einen 4-0 gegen Eindhoven kann man jetzt nicht auf die Liga kopieren, aber einfach so, was man in dem Spiel gesehen hat, wie die Spieler miteinander interagieren, wie der Weg nach vorne aussieht, auch im Spiel gegen Pireus, das sah halt richtig ordentlich aus. Und dann spielt man außerdem bei Sandhausen und es kommt eigentlich über 90 Minuten lang 10 Minuten was. Und das kann man eigentlich auf alle Spieler anwenden. Das war gegen Regensburg so, das war gegen Rostock so, das war gegen den HSV so. Und das meine ich jetzt gar nicht respektlos gegenüber all die Gegner, aber die mussten halt noch nicht mal ihr bestes Spiel zeigen. Die mussten nicht mal über 90 Minuten konzentriert Fußball spielen, die mussten nicht über 90 Minuten konzentriert verteidigen, die mussten gar nicht 90 Minuten Powerplay machen, weil Bielefeld einfach nichts, die haben, das hat Fabian Kloss auch im Gegner-Interview vor dem Heimdheim-Spiel gesagt, man hat immer 45 Minuten gebraucht, um überhaupt die Tachrik für das Spiel auf dem Rasen zu sehen. Amini hat angefangen mit einer Dreierkette hinten, weil Forte eben auch dafür bekannt war, hat dann aber im Rostock-Spiel schon zu einer Viererkette umgeswitcht, weil da auch einfach super viel Unsicherheit war. Olli Hüsing ist einfach noch nicht der Leader hinten drin, was man von ihm erwartet hatte, wie man ihn eben auch von Heidenheim und vielleicht auch von Rostock kannte. Er hatte im HSV-Spiel einen riesengroßen Patzer drin. Stefanos Kompino wird leider auch an seinen Fehlern gemessen momentan. Er war ja auch ein bisschen für das Gegenteil in Heidenheim verantwortlich. Da lief auch die Abstimmung mit Hüsing nicht im Spiel gegen den HSV. Obwohl er dann natürlich auch gegen Heidenheim gut gehalten hat. Aber es tut mir auch wirklich leid für ihn, weil er muss halt nur mal ein unfassbar schwieriges Erbe antreten, im Windschatten von Stefan Ortega. Es ist halt einfach, wenn man Stefan Ortegas Abstöße kennt, seine Spielintelligenz, und dann guckt man sich Stefanos Carpino an, und man denkt so, kann ich das nochmal sehen? Das tut mir natürlich super leid, aber es ist natürlich für einen Kader, der dann gerade in der Offensive eben sowas wie Ortega gewohnt war, gerade ein Fabi Kloss, der dann natürlich immer so ein bisschen nach vorne durch die Gegend irrt und irgendwie darauf wartet, dass der Ball eben immer zu ihm kommt, ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen unglücklich. Und dann ist es halt einfach so, also ich habe von Anfang an erwartet, dass wir in der Defensive Probleme haben könnten, weil es einfach der Mannschaftsteil mit dem größten Umbruch war. Brunner ist zu Schalke gegangen, Pieper zu Werder Bremen, Nilsson zu St. Louis in den USA, Lawson ist jetzt auch noch, glaube ich, zu Lüttich gewechselt. Und dann natürlich Ortega zu Man City. Dass ich so etwas mal sage, habe ich auch nicht gedacht, aber okay. Das heißt, 4 von 5 Spielern waren in der Ausstiegsmannschaft von 2019, 2020. Die unfassbar wichtig war, die auch über weite Strecken in der Bundesliga-Saison eben dafür gesorgt haben, dass man trotz wenig selbstgeschossener Tore gerade in der ersten Bundesliga-Saison nicht abgestiegen ist, weil man eine sehr, sehr gute Defensive hatte über weite Strecken. Und das fehlt halt einfach. Also das, worauf sich Bielefeld ihm wie immer verlassen konnte, wenn man denn schon keine Tore vorne schießt, ist, dass man zumindest nicht in jedem Spiel 8 Stück kassiert. Man kassiert zwar keine 8 Stück, aber es passiert halt einfach viel zu leicht. Hätte am Wochenende gegen Heidenheim auch passieren können. Trotzdem war das das erste Spiel dieser Saison, was Heidenheim eben nicht gewonnen hat. Sonst wären sie ja auch gleichauf mit Paderborn und Darmstadt mit 12 Punkten gewesen. Und in Heidenheim gewinnt schon mal nie leicht. Aber es ist irgendwie alles sehr unglücklich. Dann hatte man dieses Pokalspiel dazwischen, wo man ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich nicht gut gespielt hat, wo es der VfL ganz auch ganz gut gemacht hat, trotzdem irgendwie 7-1 gewonnen hat und jetzt alle dachten, ja, einfach mal dieses… Ja, genau. Und nie. Dann 2-1 gegen Rostock verloren. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Dann hat man dann Sebastian Vassiliades, wo du ja auch sehr großer Fan bist, der irgendwie gerade in den Spielen gegen Hamburg und Rostock, wo ich da echt stand, so um Himmels willen, was machst du da, da muss ich auch sagen, da war zumindest die erste Halbzeit gegen Heidenheim um das, was ich von ihm eigentlich kenne, gerade außer 2. Liga, das war viel griffiger, aber auch wieder gegen Heidenheim. 45 Minuten, gut. Die restlichen waren dann einfach körperlich nicht okay. Man muss auch sagen, anscheinend hat Bielefeld vor dem Spiel zum Beispiel gegen Regensburg morgens noch trainiert. Das muss ich auch einfach nicht verstehen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich habe mir tatsächlich mal ein Training von Aminia angeguckt, weil ich dachte, irgendwas muss ja sein. Da ist mir auch einfach aufgefallen, dass Vorte einen richtigen Teil dieses Trainings geleitet hat. Der Rest lief über Hille, über Hesse, über Henker, also den ganzen Co-Trainer und über den Athletiktrainer. Dann hört man Uli Vorte nur in vier verschiedenen Sprachen reden, was natürlich cool ist für die Spieler, was aber gleichzeitig auch irgendwie so ein bisschen selbstdarstellerisch wirkt zum Ende hin. Und, ja, gut, jetzt Daniel Scherning. Kennt Bielefeld auch, hat die Uhr 23 hier, als es die noch gab trainiert, war dann ja lange Co-Trainer unter Steffen Baumgart bei Paderborn, jetzt bei Osnabrück. Also er ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie in der Region durchaus fest verankert, so aus Westfalen und halt Osnabrück. Es war, glaube ich, ganz gut, dass man schnell einen Ersatz gefunden hat, weil ich glaube, diese ganze Co-Trainer-Sache, die hatten wir letztes Jahr schon mal, bzw. letzte Saison schon mal, möchte ich jetzt auch nicht wieder hin, weil ich glaube, das ist halt auch einfach –also ich habe von irgendjemandem gehört, ja, warum ist Kostmann denn nicht an dich Trainer geblieben? Das Problem ist natürlich, dass ein Mensch jetzt ganz, ganz stark unter Druck steht und das ist nicht der Trainer, sondern das ist Samiya Arabi. Weil eben, das muss man eben auch so sagen, wenn man sich so ein bisschen die Pressekonferenzen zur Vorstellung der Trainer anguckt, wird –also das hat Kramer, das hat Kramer, sag ich schon, das hat Arabi bei Kramer gesagt, das hat Arabi bei Kramer gesagt, das hat Arabi bei Forte gesagt und das hat Arabi jetzt wahrscheinlich gesagt, ja, ja, wir beobachten ihn schon ganz lange. Sonst habe ich jetzt drei Mal gehört. Es hat zwei Mal nicht so wahnsinnig gut funktioniert, Samiya. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das so gut ist. Und dann ist es natürlich so, die Bielefeld interessiert halt die Öffentlichkeit zu wenig, als dass da halt so drüber hergezogen wird als zum Beispiel beim HSV oder bei Schalke, wenn die wahnsinnig viele Trainer in ein paar Jahren versieben. Aber auch bei Bielefeld ist es, glaube ich, im Schnitt so, dass der längste Trainer in den letzten acht Jahren gefühlt hier halt wirklich Uwe Neuhaus war, mit fast zweien. So, und das ist natürlich nicht ideal, dass halt auch einfach eine sehr, sehr hohe Trainerfluktuation besteht. Und halt eben da es einen Sportdirektor seit zwölf Jahren gibt, wo man dann natürlich einfach mal draufschaut. Also ich möchte dazu sagen, ich halte nichts von komplett draufhauen. Also zwischendurch musste ich mich da auch aus Diskussionen ausklinken, weil es halt auch einfach, wie man das halt kennt, nicht mehr wirklich keine vernünftige Diskussion war, sondern so, ich weiß nicht, warum Araby Niggi schon seit dann und dann weg ist. Ja, okay, ohne Araby wären wir halt auch niemals aufgestiegen. Und trotzdem ist der Kader, den wir haben halt überdurchschnittlich gut für das, was wir sonst so mal in der 2. Liga als Kader hatten. Aber es ist natürlich so, der Druck ist da. Wenn es mit Scherning nicht funktioniert, glaube ich persönlich, dass nicht nur Scherning eben seinen Job verliert, sondern Sami Araby tatsächlich auch. Weil ich glaube, dann wird sich der Aufsichtsrat, dass sie auch nicht mehr lange mit angucken. Es gibt wohl durchaus schon, ja, also es heißt halt wohl so ein bisschen, dass Scherning halt so schon noch Arabis Wunschkandidat war. Aber er natürlich auch Ablöse gekostet hat, also das kam da ja natürlich auch noch zu. Genau, also das eben, das durchaus ist rund um die Position Sami Araby, glaube ich, so laut rumort wie noch nie. Wir haben ja schon mal tatsächlich, glaube ich, zum Ende der ersten Bundesliga-Saison so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass Araby eigentlich immer so ein bisschen als der Sündenbock hingestellt wird, wenn mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert, wo ich damals, glaube ich, auch sehr ihn verteidigt habe und gesagt habe, dass das zum Teil halt auch sehr, sehr unkonstruktiv ist, weil halt irgendwie dann gesagt wird, wenn acht Transfers geholt wird und einer funktioniert nicht, die restlichen sieben schon, wird gesagt, das war ein furchtbares Transferfenster. Ja, ich glaube, wie gesagt, ich glaube, dass Bielefeld gleichzeitig profitiert und gleichzeitig halt eben auch das Negative ist, dass die öffentliche Wahrnehmung sich zwar jetzt schon ein bisschen mehr auf Bielefeld konzentriert, weil man eben Bundesliga-Absteiger ist, aber halt über weite Strecken halt nicht wirklich da die Aufmerksamkeit da war und deshalb da vielleicht der Druck von außen auch nicht so groß war, wie jetzt woanders. Es ist natürlich schon krass, dass man jetzt nach vier Spieltagen gesagt hat, also dass Sami Arabi hat gesagt, man hat nicht mehr gesehen, dass Uli Vorte einen Weg findet, das rumzureißen. Das finde ich schon extrem. Also das ist schon ziemlich deutlich. Ich würde einmal ganz kurz nur, zwar ist ein Spiel nicht unfassbar groß als Grundlage, um den neuen Trainer zu bewerten, aber einfach wie gesagt ganz kurz Scherning. Ich habe mir die Pressekonferenz nach dem Spiel angeguckt und mir hat einfach sehr gut gefallen, im Gegensatz zu Vorte, dass er durchaus vor allem erstmal die Schwächen kritisiert hat. Dazu muss man glaube ich auch sagen, dass wir als Bielefeld-Fans nach der Saison –und ich möchte nicht nach Frank Kramer nachtreten, aber es ist eben so, dass man wusste, egal wie ein Spiel ausgeht, 90 Prozent der Pressekonferenz wird deckungsgleich sein zu dem, was er die Woche davor gesagt hat. Das war bei Vorte nach vielen Spieltagen so. Das ist dann natürlich einfach so, wenn auch ein Fabian Klose am ersten Spieltag sagt, ich glaube, manche Spieler wissen überhaupt nicht, worum es hier geht. Und man denkt, es ist einfach eine Fortsetzung der Bundesliga-Saison. Fantastisch, da wollte ich eigentlich raus. Dass man das Gefühl hat, cool, wir sind da, wo wir die ganze letzte Saison in der Bundesliga über waren. Einfach wirklich nur noch die gleichen Sätze, dass so etwas gesagt wird, wir hatten ja auch gute Phasen im Spiel. Ja, das kann man meinetwegen in der Bundesliga sagen, aber nicht in der 2. Bei allem Respekt, aber nach einem Spiel gegen Hansa Rostock. Das kann nicht sein, das kann nicht der Anspruch sein, ein paar gute Phasen im Spiel zu haben. Eigentlich musst du da hinkommen und halt 90 Minuten zeigen, gerade mit dem Kader, was du kannst. Scherning hatte jetzt nur 3 Tage, ich fand aber trotzdem, dass vor allem das Verteidigen hinten viel besser geklappt hat. Zum Beispiel im Spiel gegen den HSV war so, der Mensch, der die meisten Kilometer barminia gemacht hat, war Yanni Serra mit 11 Kilometern als Stürmer. Jetzt war Sebastian Vasejades mit fast 12 Kilometern. Also eigentlich die Position, wo man erwartet traditionell. Das sind die laufstärksten Spieler. Scherning hat halt gesagt, sobald man konsequenter verteidigt hat, haben sich eben gute Umschaltmomente entwickelt. Da hätte er sich halt gewünscht, dass das noch ein paar Mal öfter passiert ist. Das war natürlich alles sehr linkslastig über Ucipka. Da war Siddler, fällt da eben so ein bisschen vorn ab. Aber Ucipka fand ich sehr stark auf der linken Seite. Hat sich, also bringt halt auch einfach gute Erfahrung mit. Scherning hat halt so ein bisschen kritisiert in der zweiten Halbzeit, dass halt eben die Ketten nicht mehr eng genug standen, daher auch viel zu viele Chancen für Haldenheim entstanden sind. Man hat halt nicht gut rausgeschoben. Und dann kam natürlich auch noch die gelb-rote Karte für Jäkel dazu, wo Scherning halt sagt, gut, die zweite gelbe Karte kann er verstehen. Versteht aber halt die erste nicht so ganz, weil die halt relativ früh im Spiel war. Und halt Jäkel eigentlich das ganze Spiel über auch irgendwie von den Haldenheimern attackiert wurde. Im Endeffekt zweimal foult und dann direkt zweimal gelb sieht. Er hat dann der Vorteil, den Bielefeld da eben schon hatte, dass Scherning proaktiv reagiert hat. Da er im Prinzip schon gesehen hat, okay, mehr als ein Punkt ist heute nicht drin, ist aber auch in Haldenheim okay. Ich bringe schon mal noch mehr Defensivkräfte rein. Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt stand eh schon Ramos und Kanuric dann mit auf dem Platz. Dann wurde eben Andrade noch eingewechselt. Auch übrigens Fun Fact, ich weiß nicht, ob es daran liegt, dass Campino verletzt war. Zum Ende hin hat Ramos die Abschüsse bei uns gemacht, weil er halt anscheinend nicht mehr konnte. Ich dachte auch zwischendurch, warum fliegt der Ball, wenn Campino am anderen Ende des Strafraums steht? Fantastisch. Aber ja, genau, ich sage mal so, es war zumindest eine ordentliche Leistung, wo man aufbauen kann. Das war natürlich noch nicht alles gut, aber gerade für Robin Hack hat es mich sehr gefreut mit dem Tor, weil er wirklich einer der besten Spieler der letzten drei Wochen war oder der beste Spieler, der hier auch sehr stark in der Kritik stand. Da freut es mich einfach sehr.
Gut, also das ist die Situation bei Bielefeld. Tobi, du hattest doch mal wieder recht. Es ist genau so gekommen. Tobi hat vor der Sendung noch gesagt, Eva ist meine Zeugin, weil ich noch meinte, ich würde eigentlich ganz gerne wieder den Kurzpass auf eine Stunde und kürzer drücken und lasse mal gucken. Und Tobi hat gesagt, das habe ich bisher jedes Mal gehört, wenn ich mit dabei war, und es wurden immer eine Stunde 13. Jetzt sind wir gerade bei einer Stunde 11. Und vermutlich werde ich jetzt direkt nach der Verabschiedung bei einer Stunde 13 sein. Tobi, du hast es mal wieder kommen sehen. Du bist einfach der Rettungsmagier. Ich kriege es nicht anders hin, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr müsst mal Feedback geben, ob ihr das schlimm findet, wenn das jetzt länger ist als eine Stunde. Ich habe immer so das Gefühl, eigentlich müsste es drunter sein. Aber bei den internationalen Kurzpässen scheitere ich daran ja auch immer grandios. Und man hört ja den Gästen auch immer so gerne zu. Also gut, gebt mir mal Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Ich verabschiede mich jetzt erstmal von euch, damit wir auch genau bei 1.13 aufhören. Lieber Tobi, ich danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst. Tobias Kröger auf Twitter folgt eben dort alle, werde ich natürlich verlinken. Danke dir, Tobi, dass du mir mal wieder den HSV erklärt hast.
Vielen Dank, mache ich auch in Zukunft gerne. Hat mir Spaß gemacht, hier dabei zu sein.
Das freut mich zu hören. Und herzlichen Dank an Eva-Lotta Bohle, die EdEva unterstrich Bohle auf Twitter. Ihr wisst, dass ihr sie auch nochmal über alle Vereine reden hören könnt im 2. Bundesliga-Pod, den ich euch sehr ans Ohr legen möchte. Liebe Eva, danke dir, dass du wieder im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst. Es ist immer ein Fest.
Sehr gerne. Nächstes Mal würde ich wirklich dann nach allerhalb Jahren eher so meh im Rasenfunk gerne mal wieder über coole Phasen von Amina sprechen.
Ich verspreche dir, wenn es eine gute Phase von Bielefeld gibt, dann lade ich dich wieder ein. Ist das nicht nett von mir?
Ja, aber so wenn es irgendwann war.
Ach so, nein, das war ein zeitliches Wenn, kein konditionales Wenn. Hab ja gerade irgendwas im Auge. Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt schnell hier wenden. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Gebt mal gerne Feedback zu diesem Kurzpass. Es geht jetzt nicht direkt in der nächsten Woche weiter. Hier in Bayern sind noch Sommerferien. Ich bekomme das quasi nicht organisatorisch hin. Plus, ich arbeite an neuen Tribüngengesprächen. Ja, sowas gibt es auch noch tatsächlich im Rasenfunk-Kosmos. Also mal gucken, aber sehr wahrscheinlich gibt es dann bald was zu internationalen Ligen und Frauenfußball. Wenn da die Frauenbundesliga startet, da werde ich mir natürlich auch etwas bis dahin überlegt haben. Also bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Gebt uns gerne Feedback auf einen sozialen Netzwerken. Und natürlich auch im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und wir stellen fest, ich habe es tatsächlich geschafft, jetzt glaube ich ganz knapp über der 1.13 zu landen. Ich kann es nicht genau sagen. Alles wie immer im Rasenfunk. Schön, dass ihr trotzdem mit dabei wart. Macht's gut, bis bald, bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ciao!